all right Kevin
yes sir Kevin uh where are you from
originally where'd you grow up I was
born in Summit New Jersey which is north
north Jersey about 20 minutes from
Manhattan
I uh was raised in a small town called
Madison really nice little town up in
Jersey
um
grew up there uh wanted to be wanted to
be a police officer early in life up
there
uh eventually we moved to Sarasota
Florida
and uh
was raised there from uh
for quite a while until I decided to get
into law enforcement what was it that
made you as a Young Man wanna yeah I
don't know I always wanted to be a cop
um
I remember two detectives from New York
coming to my grandfather's house in
Madison to to look at a car he was
selling and two you know they were
dressed in regular clothes I guess they
were off and they showed up to my
grandfather's house to to look at a car
he was selling and and I just looked at
them like they were superheroes like
Batman and Robin were at the house and
uh you know it's just something I I
always knew I wanted to do that's great
and you eventually did it yeah came to
Sarasota uh applied for Sarasota's
Department
they were put me on a waiting list uh
they weren't hiring at the time
I saw the Tampa was hiring
so I moved up here to Tampa got on right
away Sarah said I got in contact me when
I was already going to the academy here
in Tampa and they wanted me to come on
there and I said sorry too late I'm
going to stay with Tampa and that's how
I got here
tell me about being a cop in Tampa how
do you think it's different than than if
you had stayed up by New York well well
the crime was bad here back in the day I
started in Patrol didn't do that long
too much paperwork didn't really like it
I went into the canine unit uh had a
good dog I enjoyed that I did that for
five years
and then I got into plain clothes street
level narcotics and I fell in love with
that because I got to go to work dress
like this
no more uniform nobody knew I was a cop
got to fool the bad guys you know make
arrests that way did you have the beard
I did not have a beard at the time I had
I wore a wig back when I did street
level we weren't allowed to have long
hair so I wore a wig that was down to
about the middle of my back
I I'd go out in a in a uh like a gas
station shirt you know some that an
employee would wear at a gas station
with a name tag and uh I probably did
more more uh undercover drug purchases
than anybody on the department at that
time I was I was good at it I had the
Gift of Gab I guess from being up up
from Jersey you know that Northeast wit
so I could talk anybody into anything
being an undercover narcotics detective
is is a bit of a jump from the cops that
came by to by your
you're oh yeah well who knows maybe
those guys were undercover narcotics
that came but uh you know I just once I
got on I and I got to wear plain clothes
and go to work undercover I I knew
that's what I wanted to do for for the
rest of my career the adrenaline has got
to be a big part of it right it is it is
it's uh
like I said I probably bought more dope
we had a unit called quad quick uniform
attack on drugs Tampa used to be
inundated with crack cocaine when crack
cocaine became
became the thing and there there were
probably a hundred intersections you
could go to here in Tampa and you'd have
it your choice of dealers there would be
anywhere from two to 15 guys selling
crack so uh it was the Wild Wild West
back in the day when I was when I was
doing it the street corners yeah
this is still going on today just in
different different it's probably still
going on when I drive through town I
don't live in in the city anymore I live
on the outskirts but when I go to
certain places I used to work in it
looks a whole lot better it's a lot
cleaner I'm sure there's still a lot of
places you can go to get street level
narcotics here but it's a whole lot
better than when I was in Quad and and
we fought against that stuff you have
some interesting stories uh a couple uh
one time I went to a hotel on Nebraska
I was uh one of my uh
informants that was a prostitute set me
up
uh to go there and and buy off of off a
black male who was in the hotel
so I knock on the door he was expecting
me through my informant
I uh bought the cocaine from him
and then the unexpected happened now
sometimes doing undercover I'd wear a
gun hide a gun sometimes I didn't it
depended on what I was doing where I was
going how I felt what I was wearing
sometimes I I did the undercover without
without having a gun with me this time
thank goodness I had one
so I bought the cocaine from the guy
and he decides to block the door I thank
him I go to the door he blocks the door
he goes you're not going anywhere until
I see you do it
well
obviously we're not allowed to do it
um don't want to do it
so when he blocked the door and he had a
prostitute in in the bed with uh in his
room she was under some covers she was
fiddling around so I didn't trust her I
didn't know if she had a gun underneath
the covers
so luckily this time I had my gun I I
reached behind me pulled my gun out
pointed it to his head and I said you
you make a move I'll blow your head off
how's that sound I'm a cop
and then the prostitute started fiddling
around under the covers and I thought
she might be going for something so I
put the gun on her and told her the same
thing I said darling you better freeze I
said while I back out of this room you
do anything that other than that you're
gonna get it so I held the gun on the
both of them uh made my way out of the
room and called in the Cavalry who you
know I had backups hiding outside the
hotel room and we made the arrest
without incident thank goodness
and you're married I'm married my wife
was a cop you met her downstairs she was
a cop for a while
I didn't really want to be married
serious with a with a female cop I
didn't want to have to worry about her
she was a nurse prior and after we
became got married and and became
you know a solid relationship she quit
the department pretty much because
that's what I want her to do and she
went back into nursing yeah she
understands the the crazy lifestyle yeah
she did but you know I didn't bring it
home you know a lot of cops live eat and
breathe this stuff to me it was just a
paycheck it really was I mean just make
sure my check's there every two weeks I
I didn't think of my job even though it
was a lot different
I didn't think of it any different than
a guy who collects garbage uh you know
the mailman I really didn't but so I
didn't take a lot of home and tell her
stories like I've I've heard a lot of
guys say they do I was able to separate
the two and I would think it'd be hard
once you started Living this lifestyle
even though you're on the right side of
the law
to just keep it separate from your
personal life yeah but I did I mean I I
was coach I was a baseball coach as well
my son was into sports I did a lot of
coaching and to be honest with you I
like that and that was more important to
me than than the job so I was easily
able to forget the job when I was off
and and get into that that part of my
life because I loved coaching yeah the
adrenaline rush though yeah well well
another good story
um
a bit of a sad story
I did Undercover for one of the biggest
street level operations probably ever I
know I know in quads history quads no
longer a unit they call it something
else now but
I had a black female informant I forget
if we I think we were paying her she
wasn't working off charges uh we we were
paying her to to take me around and do
this stuff well she took me to 40 of the
probably the top level now these weren't
huge guys selling kilos these were
street level guys but they were they you
know they were the bigger bigger street
level dealers who'd give it out to other
guys who'd go infest the you know the
street corners
she took me around to 40 of them over a
couple month period me undercover with
her in the car
and I bought dope from about 40
different
again of the bigger street level dealers
and
we didn't arrest them right away we just
identified them made sure we know knew
who they were and we saved it for a big
Roundup when when we you know had bought
from everybody we could
so we do the Roundup we get about 30 of
the 40. that day good Roundup good real
good real good uh
real good deal for us the city
uh I think we got the other 10 later we
got most of them I think we got them all
it took us a while to get the other 10.
well unfortunately the informant
after this was over
I knew a lot of them would put two and
two together I mean there they take a
risk too
um either working off charges or getting
paid to do this they're taking a risk
she received a box one day uh
I don't remember if it came through the
mail or if somebody made it look that
way and put it on her porch
the informant that took me around to do
all these cases
she takes the Box in her kitchen and it
blows up
somebody had sent her a package bomb
so she wasn't killed she was severely
hurt and uh a lot of her kitchen was was
blown up
I never did go to sear I felt kind of
bad about that you're not supposed to
get personal with your informants you
know you don't
you don't really have anything to do
with them unless you're on the job
actually working a case but I really did
want to go see her I like this girl she
did a lot for me for the city but I
never did go to see her my supervisors
did and we ended up giving her money uh
she she recovered she got out of the
hospital and the city gave her money to
uh relocate to move out of town
yeah
do you see a big difference between
the makeup of somebody who takes
you know a career on the right side of
the law and those that are on the wrong
side
oh yeah the criminals is there a big
difference
well there should be there should be
there's not there there's you know there
are certain departments
um where they they cross the line they
do things I've heard stories valid
stories
where they cross the line and in my
opinion they become criminals themselves
um
you know when I got promoted device
detective and we did the bigger cases
the kilos things like that
um
Iran I ran into thousands of dollars on
a monthly basis we seized thousands of
dollars
uh I never took a penny yeah it was drug
money and I was there counting it
seizing it from these guys who made the
money off selling drugs
uh thousands of dollars on a monthly
basis I I never even thought about
taking a penny to me that was stealing I
would have been almost just as much a
criminal as them
um you know I didn't most of my
informants were prostitutes I'd go out
and make sex cases on them instead of
charging them
I'd offer them to take me around to
their they were all on dope so instead
of charging them with a sex charge they
would work off their charges by taking
me to to uh drug dealers around the city
and and make cases on them
but uh
you know this I heard guys say they you
know they tasted the drugs you know why
would you want to taste it some of the
drugs were laced with they put poison in
drugs they put all sorts of cut stuff
to to make more money and rip people off
as opposed to selling pure stuff why is
a cop would you want to taste it we
weren't allowed to taste it
um if if I tasted drugs doing a case and
they found out I'd probably get I would
have been fired
other departments I won't name names uh
I guess got away with that
um but to me that's the wrong way to go
Tampa ran a real tight ship and I think
most apartments around the country do
now other departments get away with a
little more or have been known to be you
know corrupt some corruption
I'm not going to mention any agencies
you know who I'm you know you can
imagine who I'm talking about
um
we ran a tie chip at Tampa if you
screwed up you got in trouble if you
screwed up bad you you'd get fired if
you're really screwed up you'd be
prosecuted and arrested so
it was a tight ship runner for working
for Tampa and I'm glad I worked for an
agency like that you you worked how many
years 23 years probably three quarters
of that in in undercover whether it was
street level or or vice detective do you
see Society getting worse or better with
crime
um
well that's that's a tough question I
mean Society I think's going down the
toilet uh but not not just with drugs
uh as I said when I come into Tampa now
I see places that used to be drug
infested they're now nice looking places
so I know speaking of the city of Tampa
it's been cleaned up quite a bit and and
I'm proud to say that I was a good part
of that
um
when I got to uh when I got to Vice
uh it was harder to do undercover as as
a white male because uh they didn't they
didn't trust us
um you know if I did I did my share of
undercover but it was an advantage as a
vice detector would be black Hispanic
because sellers dealers would trust
somebody like that more than myself so I
I had to pretty much count on informants
um there's a there's an old saying a
vice detect is only as good as their
their informants and that's that's
basically true
and we get them through either a resting
a small fish we'd climb the ladder to
bigger fish with them you know reducing
their charges or some people just work
for us for money they wanted to do it
and and we'd pay them for for uh for
helping us out
your mental illness is a big thing out
there in on the streets what uh what
kind of stuff have you seen in your
career well
there's some crazy people out there
there's some crazy people I had an
informant
a black female she was a prostitute I
had made a case on her
and again she'd turn in all her drug
dealers
to not be charged for her sex charge
and she used to tell me
that she had a client who was a doctor
here in Tampa
a doctor
and he would pick her up
and take her to his home beautiful home
she said definitely looked like a
doctor's home and I was sure this guy
was really a doctor
and he would pay her
to throw rotten fruit at him naked he
would tie his hands behind his back get
naked lean over a chair and he had a
bowl of rotting fruit on a table
and he would pay her to throw
rotten fruit at his rear end splattering
it all over the place that would turn
him on and then he'd masturbate
not hurting anybody not hurting anybody
but but this is a doctor you gotta
that's kind of kind of strange
um she had another client who was a
lawyer was an attorney here in Tampa
and he'd either pick her up and take her
to his home which was another beautiful
home she said lawyer's home
or he'd take her to a hotel
what he did was he took her out and made
her eat
he'd fill her up
he'd he'd make her eat keep buying her
food buying her food until she couldn't
take anymore well they'd go back to his
house or the hotel
she'd have to poop
so when she had to go he'd have her sit
on a clear table
he'd lie underneath watching it while he
masturbated
that's that turned him on that's what he
paid her to do yeah Lifestyles of the
Rich and Famous so
you know it
there are some
there are some crazy people out there
um no doubt
um
I had prostitutes I won't name any names
I had prostitute informants
that
I went to a hotel on Dale Mabry here in
Tampa one day to set up a deal
and my informant
white little white female she was a
pretty girl
she's on the phone
and she tells me to hold on She carries
on a conversation
and she hangs up I go come on we got to
get going here what she goes I'm sorry
that was so and so won't name any names
he was a professional baseball player
um she goes he's one of my studies she
goes that was him
she goes out he's one of my steady
clients
yeah you know
teach his own but it was we also when I
was in Vice we used to do wire Taps we'd
tap people's phones the drug dealers
phones
you know through through the you know
the judge signing it and blah blah blah
and we'd listen to all the phone calls
to make cases it was called a wiretap
and I had uh we we did these dealers
here in Tampa and they would talk about
being good friends with a lot of sports
figures
they'd mention them in the uh you know
on the phone and in conversation hey I'm
going to see so and so he's flying me up
for the series this weekend and uh and
these are hardcore Big Time drug dealers
you know saying that these sports stars
are still hanging around them bringing
them to games bringing them to stay with
them and they'd mention the names and uh
it just made me wonder you know it was
it was crazy you know here you are a
successful
Big Time Sports guy and you're still
doing God knows what with these with
these street drug dealers you know
so how is how is the the career that you
had changed you
again Mark I didn't really
I wasn't
I've heard guys you've had on from other
departments say you know it you just
fell into this life
you forgot about your family blah blah
blah that that wasn't me and my family
came first what I did on my own time
came first
so it really didn't change me it it
I I'm I feel lucky blessed I did 23
years
and I have a great pension I get money
put in my account every month for for
doing nothing you're able to keep your
work your work and I was able to keep my
work my work which I've heard a lot of
guys say they weren't able to do
and I was able to keep family and
friends separate
that's great yeah yeah now I'm on a nice
pension enjoying life golfing
going to the gym
you know
living a good life off of uh a lot of
people say Kevin you earned it what you
did well that might be true but but
again
you know it was dangerous but I didn't I
really didn't think of it that way I
thought of it as just another job like
anybody else has a job you feel like it
was something that you were meant to do
I think it was something I was meant to
do there's two things I was a good
like I said I I I I was good at
more so when I was doing the street
level cases than being advice because as
I said the higher you got and you're
doing bigger case it was harder to do
undercover because of being a white male
and dealers didn't trust you they
thought you were a cop it would street
level wise
uh there I don't think there was anybody
better at the time on the department
than I was going out I'd go to I'd go to
dope holes
where they would say they will not sell
to white guys if you're white you cannot
go in there and make a case
so I would all right I'd go in there I'd
make a case
I'd like to I'd like to think I could
talk yeah I could I could talk to these
guys after they are arrested to turn in
their their mothers for for leniency
that gift to gab I guess like I said
maybe it's from being from the Northeast
work I think it's known up there to be a
little quicker a little Wittier even
though I didn't live in Jersey for a
super long time it it I'm a jersey guy
Kevin what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in in
all of this
the most important lesson
uh staying stand straight
uh not letting the job become my life
taking over my life staying on the right
side as opposed to other Detectives
that I've heard talk
um no you know
again I was blessed to to work for a
department like Tampa who was so strict
about
doing the right thing
um
real quick just to get on
again Tampa was a straight-laced police
department you you had to do the right
thing don't get me wrong we had bad
apples
there were guys that were fired there
were guys that were arrested the best
undercover guy Vice detective one of the
best probably Tampa's ever had
uh when I was doing the street level
stuff he was already a vice Detective
he
he did something with money or he was
giving out information on
on uh cops to suspects saying not to buy
from these guys he was doing something
with drug dealers
against us
and we couldn't believe it he he was
like he was like the the god of of of
undercover detectives on our department
at the time
and he got caught and he got fired and
he got prosecuted and he went to prison
so you know
there's good and bad and all I mean most
of the guys I worked with
to let people know most of the guys I
worked with out there were did the job
for the right reasons they were good
people they wanted to protect the public
they wanted to put bad guys in jail
but
you you have your bad apples no doubt
and there were plenty not not probably
as much as some agencies I I could think
of a name but we had our our share of of
people that got in trouble and I'm just
glad
Lessons Learned I I'm just glad I guess
I was able to do things the right way
throughout my career you know I never
never again never tasted any drugs never
used any drugs didn't sleep with any of
my informants I didn't
thousands of dollars I came across on a
monthly basis I could have pocketed a
thousand or two who would have known it
was Drug Money
and I've heard guys say that they did
that well to me that was wrong and it
was wrong and on on Tampa if they would
have found out I I at least would have
been fired if not prosecuted and I'm
glad I never put that to the test and
stayed on the right right side of what I
was doing
yeah all right Kevin thank you so much
for sharing your story I appreciate it
thank you fascinating thank you thank
you thank you